women's History Month ladies
we can now conclude with certainty is
not about women it's not the Women quote
unquote who have been lauded during
women's History Month by the White House
by ESPN by the culture they're all men
so there's nothing to do with women it
has everything to do with liberalism and
leftism black history month is only
tangentially related to black people
true ESPN doesn't run fawning profiles
in Rachel dollazole they haven't yet
embraced trans-racialism but likewise
you're not going to see any fawning
profiles of Clarence Thomas Thomas Soul
Booker T Washington for that matter
you're not going to see any falling
profiles of Candace Owens I don't think
no you're only going to see a certain
kind of black person